all right thanksgiving is tomorrow so
you know what that means it's time for
the media to strike cove and fear into
the hearts of americans msnbc's medical
contributor warns it's not safe to see
your family unless of course they're
vaccinated and boosted
let's be really clear
everybody that's 18 and above
needs to get the booster as long as they
are fully vaccine and boosted it's safe
to be around other people
but what if you don't know the meta the
personal medical information of
everybody coming to your dinner well
just ask
have the conversation ask the question
don't do it in a in a confrontational or
hostile way but simply inquire and if
they're not vaccinated perhaps use that
as an opportunity to say look i love you
i i want the best for you i want the
best for all of our family and all of
our friends
i would i would really appreciate it if
you would get vaccinated
even some members of the out of touch
mainstream media understand that you
know question your uncle about his
vaccination status it can be a little
bit uncomfortable
so cbs came up with another way to stay
safe during this thanksgiving
if it feels like it's going to be weird
maybe make it kind of fun say we're
going to start with hors d'oeuvres in
the garage you know we'll have drinks
we'll do our rapid test and then come on
in right you can
make it playful make it fun and then be
able to enjoy the holiday because you're
not worried about safety
these people are utterly ridiculous all
right here now to react is pete heck
seth and rachel campos-duffy both
co-hosts of fox and friends weekend and
one of them is my beautiful wife and
it's not pete um
thank you both for coming so pete you
know what i don't think anyone is going
to ask you to come to their thanksgiving
dinner and show your vax card but if
they did pete what kind of response
would you have what is the heggseth
advice for every american who's going to
a dinner and someone wants them to show
their vaccination status ah it's it's
not going to happen that's why you saw
the laughter the way you did here's what
i imagine right now driving up to my
uncle brad's house real guy you know in
minnesota uncle brad's out front with
his sheet asking questions about your
covet status then if you don't meet the
criteria sends you over to aunt
on donna who happens to be a nurse so
that's helpful and she could administer
a booster shot and then a covet test
rapid test if necessary and only if you
get past uncle brad and on donna then
you can go in and enjoy your family
dinner that would go great you know i
mean everyone would love that and i'm
sure it would lead to just festive
environment inside uh why they laugh is
because they know it's absurd even they
themselves wouldn't follow it and oh by
the way you guys know a little bit about
the upper midwest hors d'oeuvres in the
garage in november does not sound
delightful as you know as wisconsin and
minnesota guys you'll have your woolies
on and parka outside waiting for the
test results to come back pete but you
know rachel faucia has made some
comments as well about advice on how to
stay safe during thanksgiving let's take
a look
we all getting together for christmas
for sure the whole family including the
dogs you get vaccinated you surround
yourself with vaccinated people
and you get boosted and when you're in a
congregate setting outside of the family
setting you wear a mask because you're
not sure what the status of these people
are
all right rachel uh what take do you
have on dr fauci's advice okay so i
noticed two things about this clip i
noticed he brought up the dogs i think
he's trying to redeem himself with all
the dog lovers out there for one for two
the second part is actually very
dangerous to me he says you need to
surround yourself with vaccinated people
so that means you need to divide your
family you need to separate your family
you talked earlier with christie gnome
about you know erasing history very
marxist also turning families against
each other very marxist
listen this is the time families getting
together at thanksgiving gets a bad rap
because people talk about religion and
politics and there's fighting but that's
exactly what should happen it's there at
that family in table in the safety and
love of family that we learn to disagree
we learn to be tolerant we learn to
figure out that you know our families
are more important than politics if we
can't do this with our own family
because we're not inviting them because
they decided not to take orders from the
government well guess what we're never
going to learn how to have those
important conversations and be united
with the greater american family this is
very dangerous i don't like it but you
know isn't it it was like the great part
of thanksgiving the family gets together
you talk politics you all fight right
and you know
i don't know who you as donna and and
george from the hexa brad from their
excess you know their liberals and
pete's throwing the heat at them that's
what's so great about thanksgiving and
this makes it so memorable and you know
you you have the government saying
everyone has to be double triple vexed
and boosted and wear masks
the the table that i want to be at is i
want to be there with people who have
had covered pete people who have
survived covet that i think is the
safest table that you could be at like
like the three of us am i wrong some
natural immunity
goes a long way it's true i mean you're
right if now thankfully todd uh todd's
my other uncle and lisa they're both
deplorables too but brad and donna are
deplorables so if you go there they'll
probably issue a hockey mask if you ask
for a mask and if you ask for a shot
they'll just give you a jello shot and
that's what we're looking for at
thanksgiving fun festive family talk a
little politics tell some jokes and
ultimately it's all rooted in gratitude
and there's such a lack of gratitude
elsewhere uh i think that might be why
so many in the left hate this holiday
you know in my house when you talk about
shots we might start doing niagameister
pete or rachel's a little shot at
tequila but uh there's no shot in the um
you two uh great job on fox and friends
weekend and rachel i'll see you later
tonight so i appreciate you guys joining
me
can i say one more thing sean one more
thing i would never say the best way to
be
okay the best way to be grateful for for
being an american is to act like an
american stop taking orders from the
government and remember that you were
born free 100 so you guys don't miss
petey's guest hosting hannity tonight at
9 00 pm and rachel and i will be on the
ingram angle and that's at 10. hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else